في خضمي ما تعيشه ايران من هزات ارضيه
اجتماعيه وحتى سياسيه لا تقتصر على
علاقاتها مع الخارج يمكن القول ان الارض
تهتز فعليا بفعل زلزال اقتصادي ارتداداته
تزداد عن فن يوما بعد اخر فقدت العمله
الايرانيه نحو خمسين في المئه من قيمتها
تقريبا منذ اندلاع الاحتجاجات في سبتمبر
الماضي الدولار وصل لمستوى قياسي امام
تومان اكثر من 57 الفا لكن ما السبب هناك
ميلاد امن للتبرير الاحتجاجات والعدو عدو
ايران لجا الى خلق التضخم في سوق العملات
لاستهداف المواطنين واستهداف حياتهم
ومعيشتهم
حتى نوفمبر 2022 لم يرتفع سعر الدولار
باكثر من 2000 توما اي اننا استلمنا وكان
سعره
27,600 توما اي عندما بدات حكومتنا كانت
اقل من 30 الف تومان لذا هذه القفزه
بحوالي 20000
مشكوك فيها من اين اتت لا اريد ان اقول
انها ايدي الاجانب فقط
عمليا يلمس الناس ذلك بشكل واضح في
الاسواق كل شيء ارتفع سعره وتحولت ابسط
الاشياء لاحلام وهكذا يروي الايرانيون
الامهم لكن المفارقه ان هذا التدني الحاد
في قيمه الريال الايرانيه بعد شهر او اكثر
بقليل على تعهد رئيس بحد ذاته بمواجهه
الوضع الاقتصادي والمالي المتدهور
اتمنى بعون الله وحسب هذه المؤشرات التي
قدمتها وكلها تشير الى النمو تاكدوا من ان
سعر العمله والذهب والعديد من الغلاء في
البلد ثقوا بانه سينخفض باذن الله
غير ان هذه الاسابيع جاءت بما لا تشتهيه
حكومه الرئيس يقرر البنك المركزي الايراني
ضخه 700 مليون دولار في سوق النقد الاجنبي
للحد من تدهور الريال امام العملات
الرئيسيه
خطاباته رئيسيه لم تقنع المواطنين الذين
لجاوا الى الدولارات والعملات الصعبه
الاخرى او الذهب لحفظ مدخراتهم كلمات
رئيسي لم تقنع المواطنين وحتى الصحافه بل
اعضاء في البرلمان الذين عبروا عن بالك
بطريقتهم
بحاج رئيسي اخبرتك حضوريا في البرلمان عن
عدم وجود تنسيق بين فريقك الاقتصادي لكن
لم يحدث شيئا يا سيد رئيسي فريقك
الاقتصادي بلا خطه وضعيف خذ الامر على
محمل الجد الى متى سيتعين على الناس دفع
ثمن سوء الاداره وعدم كفاءه المسؤولين